Jamie Thanks thank you good yeah what oh
my gosh how are you how you guys doing
we come from the west coast it was
pretty it was hot out there
yeah but yeah basically I mean his album
was gonna drop you guys are on the same
line wait wait what I just found on my
perspective humble gratitude like the
way he looks at things is literally like
preaching you know what I mean and then
I'm a Detroit equals 8 mile mile thesis
on life is the last scene of eight
literally my thesis on life is the last
scene of a mile which is if I tell you
all the [ __ ] I suck at yeah what you got
left right like that's literally how I
think about it tell your troops of all
your shortcomings like this is my report
card I put in a frame and I make sure
everybody sees it these apps worst in
class like damn yeah that's a real
pretty fire is it Mike I actually have
my assistant reach out to my high school
I was like I get the rights to my report
card right you need to send it to me
they said look I got four A's in high
school all in gym
everything else is D's and F's a lot bro
I gotta tell you like this view is crazy
crazy right yeah it's it's funny man
I picked it cuz Madison Square Gardens
they're all right there yeah there's not
our legacy I appreciate you come through
New York a lot or no um I'm here often
Roger yeah so tell me what's going on
you guys like what's what's like
obviously album focus is real right yeah
yeah definitely wanna drop an album may
you live activated activated and um I
chose many activated cuz I feel like
everybody get activated and they always
you know but in my way in particular all
you want to be able to like bonzi
realized I wanted to be like a rapper or
bacon rapper yeah in industry you know
are going to so cake Martella if people
like and when do you know you've had the
potential skill to actually you know
obviously like so many kids want to be
athletes and rat
furs and business people like how early
were like wait a minute I think I can
actually do it not just wish I could be
it right now I always rep trite yep but
it was my the way we're like oh you're
bad like you got it yeah yeah yeah but
it never went no further than that right
so it was something like 99.9% of people
yeah it was it was something missing so
I'm like okay what I got to do how no
all right I'm the best news I don't know
what to do so I get live help and how
are you dropping it back then I make a
song Wow SoundCloud - or not at that
time no I understood so when I got
mocked up right and how old are you now
um I just on 24 March 23rd okay and you
got locked up when I was 19 okay keep
talking so I get locked up off the rig
my first time one a prison I was in the
holiday for state very far away but it's
a um you know you get to talking to
people you get to mingling you get
emotional have your old house out there
rapid which I owe you something
mm-hmm so I'll rat fall I'll grab for
some stuff that everybody in city lives
and I was like nah brother hanging here
my day okay oh maybe that's what's
missing like damn I don't connect mica
this some super Detroit [ __ ] yeah you
know and they was critiquing me I got
locked up in so many different states it
is one time like I think it's moving you
yeah they kept on moving me so you fill
your fan base and God look you like
literally crafted it and got context
that exact much [ __ ] sense but I'm
like okay baby y'all like this type of
music here what can I do how about you
get moved
I got move about five six times did by
the third time you're like wait a minute
this is a good thing cuz I'm gonna craft
and yeah my crap yeah play the first
time like [ __ ] yeah I'm like wait a
minute the first time laughs so far like
oh no no money I'm gonna get no visits
nothing crazy but did
ooh and I like this one I like you broke
the stuff you're talking about is
respect I'm respected but we don't know
about that knowledge you read about all
schools we all like we like newer cars
like everybody dreams to get a new car
you wrecked my old school
okay come down here and be successful I
did wrecking ball stuff there's
Universal or a flaw stuff it's popular
you know the that's right you know all
you've ever bought is all you need to
write about is losing think people like
everybody like violence everybody who
also money though everybody want to have
fun everybody go to parties so puts both
energy into it they put some old are you
right in the whole time or you just go
from the dome or how do you know I was
right near and go for inaudible mm-hmm I
don't know I really write in my healing
all right I'll never you know far it
wasn't long either be like this like
this okay right boom Castlebar repeat
that I remember that [ __ ] uh-huh well
basically just moving around just help
me critiqued it come aboard University
and would you get along we lucked up
I liked up for three years and how'd it
feel when you got out like like happy
took a little while to get it feels
really is like it's like say if they
told you it's another planet
yeah if it's another planet it's just
like Earth with ten times better
uh-huh you like your lights don't ever
have to get cut off is so much energy
what kinda it is like well you get there
okay well you go next and I see like oh
you know how to feel when I first came
go back to Detroit yeah I know how to
feel I saw people's all caught up
Oh Instagram I mean the histogram is so
low I really hate you know it sound like
I'm not working on like the only trying
to hit you a Facebook I'm like alright
that's super-complicated all the day
yesterday to say fruit was tweeted
that's right the only thing that seemed
so right to music school this yeah cuz
look it's like this alright I'll keep
out of college
mm-hmm and I told I come back in 2018
mm-hmm
I got out 2016 it's something I come
back 2018 so I'm like okay I'm gonna try
to rap tang and his rap thing don't
worry about time I'm gonna get a little
school I get it because I know you set a
time limit
yeah I'm like I'm not going back cuz
that ain't funny like I don't want to
open it that's not funny oh you know I'm
like freezing that day for those setting
for know people who trying to make them
very likely so that's I feel I guess for
like people that need help
rooo rehabilitation you didn't so I'm
like I'm not going back there at all so
you see the rap and get a job of it so I
go back to school
so when I first came home first they
have first off that drop it off really
yes that's the best man you didn't have
to wait even mad didn't have to wait I
was in don't you put it on YouTube -
yeah put the volumes loop and just went
yeah my parole for I you need to get a
job where I'm like you better go off
course um
I saw the videos the first day out I had
no money like she pays for everything
video I'll see anything you know so we
did their video come back she's a new
video and I'm across the island I
watched a video of 12 times like door
that's my first video I ever shot so I'm
like damn I finally got a video they
okay waking up a lot of you don't even
on home on a surprise alert this video
yeah yeah yeah yeah game
[Music]
like and gee when we spoke with Jeezy
that are talking about how like he
should like for you guys this is the guy
jeez it's like [ __ ] super heavy so
what a feeling well some wedding is
aiming a blessing
so grateful it for so definitely I feel
like so what happened off of that off of
us all mm-hmm awful song like I'm drunk
so like a we later I started noticing I
got I'm starting to get a lot of
Instagram which is a lot of work this eg
oh you love you followers a lot of these
deals and it's like people like all
Iraqi was right here in Cali Raqqa which
will alert oh my daily crazy don't want
to see how much I'm about to do I'm here
to drop another one so that's just going
next thing you know 21 savage to me a
deal
he'd some I want to bring you up I'm uh
so worried luckily I'm sitting like that
I got before no autocycle other
celebrities DME for my number I'm on
FaceTime with them and if you don't so
we won't gone back yeah I'm gonna go to
her great I want you come on through my
back what's wrong with them and it has
been like that ever since need every is
still like wellness right I look good
LeBron James reppin this Oliver jay-z
some yellow interviews or look Instagram
famous females doctor song playing
background what he did mmm like that is
just crazy sitting over so now what what
are you guys debating as a crew net like
what's like the big decision next the
big decision is basically what to do
some rule the culture I want to do is
like cuz that firstly I'm like oh god I
really like to suit the culture like a
lot of people was like he I believe what
he's saying I like I like it means a lot
so I'm basically just trying to keep on
reaching out to people outside of music
you know talking to people going to
school one city schools build a
relationship with people and just
you know drop the Desmond it's cool
what do you think I think she is
something different and special and
fresh and within reason industry and he
has a lot to offer what I like about him
is that I'm gonna say ninety nine point
six percent of what he's rapping is his
life and it's true yeah every you know
it's what he's going through
what he went through what he's going
through and what he was about to go
through yeah and that truth wins all
truth [ __ ] wins yes yeah it's
definitely there and I think he should
collab with some different things to get
awareness in other pockets yeah and you
guys are friends are you part of the
crew what's the story here mm-hmm you
live in Detroit yes you guys grew up
together huh
so you think he should collab with
things like like as rogue as like EDM
artists and like in like country or you
mean like just different pockets of
hip-hop not so much like Atlanta or like
how are you thinking about just curious
how do you think about that from a music
standpoint I feel like it's definitely a
move to mate it's just that this you
know this is all new to me I can't risk
a pretty good listen I get it
I'm listening real carefully man that's
why I like clicking you know I know
enough like I know the things you're
talking about but hearing them from you
and your perspective is the only way I
can really understand it right yeah
people watch from the outside like you
know why I have this because when I tell
people like oh I was a bad student and
like you can do this they don't believe
me
because most people see success they
don't see the [ __ ] beforehand
I'm like no shear say I [ __ ] failed
on my classes I'm one of the best public
speakers in the world I got the in
speech to give a [ __ ] talk ID in
speech like 15 year-olds need to hear
that because I thought I was [ __ ] or at
least I didn't but they tried to make me
believe it yeah that's later that's a
late are you doing a good job taking a
step back and like really like just like
to yourself like cuz that's a lot fast
that's like from zero to hero real quick
yeah you need to be kick nothing I don't
know you like some people can handle it
you know but that's something I'm
honestly just hearing you say it makes
me happy cuz I'm like okay good he's
thoughtful about it yeah it's like I'll
be I'll be taking this time to myself
it's a thing but anyway there's so much
happening it's so much to be doing I'll
be really good times yeah soon as you
try to start thinking some crazy
person's DMing you or some phones ring
in somebody's got something to do and
you
then she just ranked out of the theater
for the kids to see Black Panther yeah
if you try without to theater for my own
little high school that's what's up see
like that there's a good job oh man
that's exactly right
Bruce to yourself right and do them
right but if you like you give you
having another thing you have a lot of
people that you won't stuff room or
space over
I got sports agency now me my brother
you've got cousins you never heard of
people just make up stories of like
fourth grade when I took care of you
what are you talk just making [ __ ] up
these kids what I see the DMS you know
like yo you're about to be in the league
like don't forget your man these are
people get people I was like okay
everybody whoo-hoo-hoo I've arrived
I'm paying your bed no I don't want
Rob's people go you get this crazy lady
will go to the school so watch your IV
it being crazy you really did that you
like went back in your head and you like
made whole with all those people yeah I
paid him on baby
but I knew who all it was done of course
because I was only charged when he
surprised oh oh I see they think they
have to make no contact I got it I'll
just pay it gave money to the state and
they gave to them I got it got what if
you like got it this is like oh how do
we get connected like what happened you
did an opera so I've known her for maybe
almost about a year I'm happy we how'd
you guys get connected through key 21
savages manager she's amazing he was
like hey my kid Gary you're great people
and jb is the person that know so
they're just connect the dots and I mean
without a doubt soccer anybody was to
know without a doubt like you know this
is the guy I know he told me I'm guy
like he's honest and that's what
everyone Midwest wants to hear that
normally
that's what everybody wants to hear
period New York Cali Atlanta the truth
is always gonna win the long game you
can fake people for a minute a problem
and he doesn't reverse engineering you
know what I mean like sorry I don't know
that look so stuck and that's like
Gary's little day that's why on the way
you start with the finish line go
backwards everything I do is to buy the
New York Jets professionally everything
and everything I do like with my content
everything is to have a legacy so the
world stops when I die that's it you
know my family life got that mission I
got my kind of like black and white
business thing which is like me get five
two [ __ ] Jets win some Super Bowls
and and then I've got my kind of like
this part which is like leave a legacy
like have interesting meetings say one
thing that might help a kid buddy help a
person you know yeah so many nuances to
every story
like I'm gonna put this on youtube
something you know I get email I get 10
emails a day people watching my content
better locked up yeah it might be some
guy sitting right now it's a gal you
know I'm just like like and just be like
wait a minute
you literally sat here and said I saw
the opportunity in my situation mm-hmm
that's the [ __ ] game man definitely I
mean man is well you were there that's a
whole nother world it literally is a
whole nother world why you don't know
but I do I know you know what I mean
even though leg was very lucky when I
get back to the world of this like it's
a whole nother life you live now well
that first you have to see how people
move them like damn really like these
and he regretted real aggressive like
like Saint saying you you I don't never
say where him
now here's put it back okay everything
good if you do that interview getting
butchered literally yeah indeed when you
come home if you trying to reach out to
you and they think oh he tanked or
prison made no bitter but it's not like
that it's like I can't reach out to you
when I'm in there and you know where I
met you didn't reach out to me was no
longer there's a lot going oh I gotta go
that and I'm not about to reach out to
you or even I thought it was just awful
oh I get it man spend your situations
double bonkers because there wasn't a
lot of time in between you know like
it's even hard like it's real easy if
you were locked up for three years back
in Detroit for 15 months and then [ __ ]
started popping then you could audited
nobody even had a breath you didn't have
a breath they didn't have a breath yeah
like if you're talking about like that's
it like the timing you just taught I
didn't really know like I heard a story
back then look at you know but I thought
there was more time all right so look I
got empathy actually for both you and
that other party that were making that I
don't know who we're talking about cuz
there was no time mm-hmm it was out her
like a literally like a week two weeks
that's heavy man
so the weird thing is how you were so
bad in school he was great in school and
like even went to college and like it
was gonna do the finance thing like
you're actually like smart school
smarter than most people I gotta fight
you got that whole that's interesting
you can really teach kids you know so
many kids look up do you probably hate
school and you can be like oh I love
school or you know what I'm saying you
say whatever you want but it was up
there I have like a 3/8
[Music]
that's [ __ ] crazy what I get I got
1.67
you go my class rank was I was right 243
at a 254 that's what's up man Michigan
State a full ride at Michigan State it's
good pretty man listen
Detroit's real interesting I'm real
friendly with Dan Gilbert is that right
I have to deal with him in a couple
weeks like I'm actually thinking about
opening off with this like the Troy is
on the short list of intermedius next
office I love what's going on in Detroit
and such an easy flight from New York
it's a boot you know she was like just
like a drop you know feel so close I
know you know yeah I always think it's a
different time New Yorkers always think
the Troy's a different time zone you
know every time I land I'm like oh no
all right with that relationship there
we're shooting his next video in one of
his properties just you know I mean so
we want to build relationships and keep
them stronger while we're building his
brain what do you want to happen what
are some of the pillars you want to win
and besides music from an
entrepreneurial standpoint honestly yeah
too early to even really think about it
that heavy well uh you like it like it
later okay
my whole life it'd be so hard to me for
me to Handy's time conversation cuz I
understand but it's like when it's time
for me to put something on the table
anyway there cuz it's like my whole life
I was never exposed to no business no
legal again he loves in so I'm really
just not learning it it's something he
was like okay you know XYZ so why you
getting to know me you could tell me
what's wrong I got you
I'll do some real homework I understand
the same way listen I grew up that way
listening well I didn't go to business
school I know exactly what you're
talking about and honestly like my my
core friends group in Kyle I went to
Mount Ida college all my friends went to
prison for real so like I really
understand what you're talking about
so I get it like my friends made their
money selling weed and robbing people
and playing Cee Lo and [ __ ] I get it
yeah I really understand what you're
saying I may not look like I understand
what you're saying but I really
understand and what once nicely sent me
wrong to lobby so committed his life is
like that's why I was about to get the
earnest the other day because my okay
when I finally got a glimpse Arsenio and
it's like they tell me who they are what
they have to offer this is all I knew
about so I'm like I'm gonna try my best
so just like crush this you know so
every day I'm just emailing the lady the
recruit who come every day I'm emailing
her whatever c-come on tennis I'm taking
her to lunch and stuff like that I mean
I can stay yeah you had to have a
certain GPA and you had to be because
it's a profile look like what before I
didn't do none of this I need
requirements and records he liked me so
much he charisma her yes missing large
that you go you gotta come to Chicago so
the global perspectives conference and
you get into the last program internship
embody what I have no money up there why
is it a family ain't no support no money
on the table so I'm like do I go for
what I know at this point so I could
kind of get this did this kind of go you
know getting caught up that was it
that's how went down yeah [ __ ] I get it
listen man thank God life is long yeah
right thank God life is long I'm glad we
met this was real enjoyable yeah it's
cool he's so honest about everything
honestly and you know this you know how
many and you probably knows I do a lot
of these tens and 15s but let's do a
dinner yeah oh yeah like this one this
one I want to build on so when you gonna
be back yeah this is super close
my name is Sean all right let's talk
yeah may 11 yeah we got to be ready for
that to him give that some exposure
I preserve my team we do a pleasure man
I really like your vibe a lot thank you
I appreciate it I got pleasure I'm glad
we met
finally in the waiting all right a lot
of learners walk I was over Chris Brown
house at his studio set up he's got so
much collectible stuff and like to come
and see this probably sign he can do
something like this with all our stuff
[Music]